here's what would happen if you ate 100  hot dogs in one day  you'd start at 8 A.M giving you about a  16 hour window to eat your 100 hot dogs  the challenge would give you two  thousand percent of your daily  recommended salt intake your cholesterol  levels would soar and your risk of heart  attack and stroke would rise with them  okay but heart attack smart attack  you're still doing it right say you gave  yourself 10 minutes per Hot Dog by 1 pm  you'd have downed 30 hot dogs you'd feel  tired nauseous and sweaty hour by hour  your stomach would stretch and your  organs would get moved around get ready  for heartburn gas and stomach pain after  you're done you'd have ingested over 31  000 calories for this challenge You'd  Survive but probably be turned off hot  dogs for the foreseeable future so